This is it your bachelorette weekend what's on my head there's gonna be so many hot Miami babes. We are gonna be swimming and dick girl
Hi Alice
Peter hi and get out of here. She's mine now. Yeah, I'm getting too much trouble. Okay? Yeah
We don't get to see each other a lot because we're all so busy with our lives different woody do for work these days
Well sing a song Roger is the dream potty clown is the reality but this weekend is all about us just like old times
From The busboy so everyone's an
Animal stop being a stupid fucking con and you love fucking cocaine
Sorry, I did a little bit of it
Beans let's get to the main mic and feel special
No-no-no flipped over and then won't publicly let's get rid of all the drugs on it. Nobody doing them. Okay
So what tell me what to do and I will do it
Huh?
My uncle's a lawyer should call him first. So this is an accident. Thank God don't touch the body. What?
Okay. So actually we have already moved here that could be up to 15 years in prison. Oh my god
This can still be the best weekend ever fucking odds
Just by a little bit right smile more
Hi baby boy sleep now. Oh no. No, no